voodoo はい
24歳ですじゃあやばいず youtube はじめたのが確か19歳だったなぁそれ
からもうすぐもう5年経とうとしてますよ
びっくりマジで開いておりでただいまですねはいただいま2月13日の23時52前
あと8分で
鍛造日でございます8ですねええ
一人で一人ですけども誕生日前から本当にたくさんの方がおめでとうございますとより
くらいでいただいて僕は本当に幸せだと思っております本当にありがとうござい
来年にはもう20代法案でございますよ同市やー
本当にまさか僕の人生がこんなことになると思っていなかったので今後のほどは全く
わかんないんですけども皆様のおかげでとても楽しく人生を過ごさせていただいており
ます
なんでこんな話をしている間にあと7分だあったらひとまずあれだなぁ
10丼食べよあの今回の動画何をするかと言いますと僕
あの誕生日の予定何も入れてません全くゼロです重度んだいね美味しそうです
今年はもう本当にねあ事前にも何も聞いてないを立てが来るところ何も聞いてないん
ですけど誰かしら僕の家に来てくれるでしょうリアルな友達が本当僕ですねのネット
番長なんでほんとネットだけなんですよ
多くの棲家というのはあっ
そう思ってた去年まではでも今年はねいう業とかも通してリアルな友達がたくさん増え
たなって僕自社を持っているので僕の誕生日がどんなのかっていうのはちょっとで皆
さんと共有しましょう
おっと気づけば残り小スンダ a fire と3分で謎3分手三染がやばい際に来て
ねーから誰も来てねーや
あと2分あと2023めでとうございます本当にありがとうございます
いいケーキですね凄い本当にありがとうめこに囲まれている後に二
後2軍あと1分勝手に感覚なと一変はほんとねありがとうとしか言いようがないでお
時間を許す限りなるべく見ております本当に twitter で絡んでくださる皆様
いつも動画を見てください
な様ありがとうございますああ
スターぞろいなんだ
食べ半端い twitter がどうなってるか
[音楽]
暗いんだ
米のああああ
dare
goo
うわあああああ
ありがとうご座さんビックリしたあれよと
ですか
いやを使ったどーっタイミングください
rr 2分頃してなんてすごいまじかっけえーだってあのは食べられず
ああああだぞろうそくありがとう
ほんと組2分ああわああああっっっ
時間時間時間あったらほんとなぜ一人です
牛丼食いならちょっと twitter 見てたありがとうございます本当によぞ
これを送付水選んだよなぁ
ん
あんまり徹夜で有意義をしないように育てソーラーがそれは違ったか
が売れば使わない
それは違う穴やで偉業やなぁ
まずは twitter ついたみなさん本当はメジャーありがとうございますが早速
ありがとうございます
それは面白いし
j
[音楽]
bouvet まずで
を得られずじゃないかじゃあ開けますねーブーバー皆さんからのディップがーうー
ダーダーね男女
いますよどうぞ
[音楽]
ああなるほどねー
前原氏に入ってなかった麻生かあってもずーっと
見参ざあけんねー特徴家で一人でよくからうち一人で行こうか月で行われたくても出来
ませんばろーっ
アンフェアです
たギアそう言うよ
えなにこれ自分で作ったのってうそーじゃん検事がたい
まずとみてください
あっ閉店ちゃんいただけました
と呼ばれですねゲスぎゃー
ああああああ
入って落ちるよね落ちるよね下がって正しいだって言ってるよなっ
beha いいいい
これっ
濡れねぇんでやばいやばい
部屋そうだったのでクモの巣をつくってみたけどな
懐かしいねぇアーティバースデー
いやぁああああああおめでとます
ni
陶器製お箸可愛い
うれしかったねもかっくれっ
じゃ全然ない見てるやを
なんとなんとなんと24南行きました
わーですよちょっと24ちゃん
このちゃんと24で止まっておりますたいというわけで24歳の誕生日はネットだけで
はなくリアルの方も充実しておりました本当にありがとうございます三24歳も結果
なく健康に過ごせればいい
いいなと思っております皆さん今後ともよろしくダサい
goo
ていた
[音楽]
いきます花の木ツアー
[拍手]